[Musique]
c'est une adresse mais encore un lieu
sûr à paris pourquoi aurais je besoin
d'un lieu sûr à paris si les choses à un
moment donné tourne vraiment mal il sera
bon d'avoir un endroit pour vous savez
boire une tasse de thé mes frères mes
soeurs leur tour
tel est mon rêve pour nous qui vivons
pour la vérité pour l'amour le moment
est venu d'occuper la place qui nous
revient de droit
dans un monde où les sorciers
turon libre
rejoignez moi
au mouret
le monde des sorciers des non sorciers
vivre en paix depuis plus d'un siècle
pringle valdes veut détruire cette paix
et vous voulez que j'ai le pourchasse
pour le tuer
[Musique]
dans un bol d'or pourquoi n'y arrive pas
je ne peux pas m'en prendre à grim
talent
il faut que ce soit avant
tu n'es pas le mal des transports si je
suis pas à l'aise en bateau
savez vous pourquoi je vous ai dit à
norbert
ne visez pas le pouvoir vous demandez
simplement une chose
et juste à
leur approche
[Musique]
tu vas devoir choisir ton camp
moi je ne choisit pas de camp
qu'allez vous faire
[Musique]
je vais trouver une idée
norbert il n'y a pas un monstre auquel
tu me rattache ma la trappe
c'est votre frère tu crois bien que
c'était le meilleur moment de ma vie